Frank Isola does MBA XM radio
I sold a show pti writer for the
athletic big Knickerbocker and Nets
writer Frank how you doing brother look
at Ryan hosting a show not that easy
right a lot of things you got to do a
little bit different there being an
analyst isn't it you know what Frank did
you tell me tell me I can't do it I'm
gonna go out and I'm gonna figure it out
brother that's a little bit different
though but now he's a point guard
you're not just you're not you know just
the guys come on a pick-and-roll get in
the ball you got to set everybody up
absolutely absolutely my man my man help
me out here man what's going on I'm
gonna call him your Knicks right now
what what should they do go after KD go
heavy and free agency wait sit back and
chill take the Lakers route what's going
on in New York you know it's an
interesting dilemma for them because if
they can get Kevin Durant
you know the Knicks over the years have
gotten burned by the contracts of
Antonio McDyess injures Allan Houston
signed a big contract he had a knee
issue then of course most recently
Amar'e Stoudemire
and you know if you do sign Kevin Durant
we know that he's not going to play next
fees and he's going to be recovering
from that surgery so by the time he's
ready to play an NBA game it'll be 16
months out from the last time he played
he'll be 32 I'm not saying you can't
come back and play at a high level but
you know if you're the Knicks you got
this young roster is that really the way
you want to go Ryan I think if they can
get them they're definitely gonna do it
but I for Team like the Knicks I think
it's a little bit of a risk right now to
tell you to take that chance if you're
Kevin Durant is it a smart chance to go
their choice to go there if Kyrie Irving
goes in Brooklyn and he's the lone Nick
would that make sense at all for Katie I
don't think it does I mean first of all
I think him going back to the Warriors
makes a ton of sense because they
contain the most the fans there have a
different level of appreciation and
respect for him after what happened in
the NBA Finals and he thought you know
like I said he can make the most money
and when you come back Ryan he's still
gonna have Steph Curry draymond Green
and klay Thompson as teammates but if I
think the biggest thing and you would
know better because you played I mean
it's
if I'm Kevin Durant you also have to
factor in am i with the right people to
help me get back to the level I was at
before the injury just in terms of the
medical staff and the physios and things
like that because if you think about
what happened with Kawhi Leonard in
Toronto you know the gentleman alex
McKechnie the physio that they have up
there with the raptors you know he did a
really good job with Kawhi Leonard in
Kauai yes he did miss 22 games during
the regular season he played in every
playoff game and he was the best part of
this postseason so I think a big part of
where Kevin Durant goes yes teammates
should factor into it money is going to
factor into it but he should also be
looking out for you know what staff
medical staff trainers physios is the
best for me to get back to you know
being an all-star caliber player Frank
helped me out here with this Brooklyn
situation because they've come into play
with Kyrie Irving looking to be the
favorite to land there then D'Angelo
Russell is flirting somewhere around
there is he staying easy going they're
gonna part ways with the guy they built
up to be an all-star and Kevin Durant
possibly gone there so oh what's the
latest there break that down for me well
I think Ryan I think if you look at
every move that the Nets have made it
seems like it's setting up for both
Kyrie Irving and Kevin Durant and from
everything that we hear and now the
reports have come out about the two of
them have met twice once the two of them
I mean Kyrie and Kevin Durant once out
in the bay area one before the Achilles
injury and that has been in New York
since he Achilles injury I had heard
that they were actually going to go on
vacation they were going to get away
together at some point after the season
and that all changed once Kevin Durant
ruptured his Achilles but the Nets
appear to be in a pretty good position
and I was just talking about the rehab
for Kevin Durant the surgeon that he
used for the ten kilise tendon is dr.
Martin O'Malley here in New York and he
is the next team doctor so he does have
a connection there and Kyrie it sounds
like Harry would prefer to play in New
York so that's the thing do you see the
two of them splitting up doesn't it seem
to make sense that they would probably
end up together I guess they could split
up but at this point it just doesn't
seem to make sense that both would come
to New York
but both would play for different teams
no I completely agree and Brian hit win
horse reported that they were open a
sign-and-trade scenario with Kevin
Durant we're talking about the Warriors
and and possibly Brooklyn but when I
hear silent rant I think Clippers I
think Brooklyn how do you think that
scenario can played out because if you
look at this Golden State roster they're
gonna be needing fresh bodies too klay
Thompson is gonna be out Katie whether
he stays or goes he won't be playing so
what do you make of that if I'm if I'm
Golden State and I can do a
sign-and-trade I would definitely do
that is I want to bring them back but if
I can't but and then get something for
him
absolutely I think the big thing with
the Warriors next year so if you're
Steve Kerr Ryan what do you do with
draymond Green and Steph Curry let's
assume they're both going to be healthy
to start of the season are you gonna run
those guys into the ground I understand
you you have a new building but what are
you be thinking I'm thinking like
between 50 and 65 games until what at
least one of these guys come back
because what would be the point of
running them into the ground hoping you
get the eight seed we're really not
having a legitimate chance to win a
championship so I think next season for
the wards every guy in that roster but
especially curry and draymond Green it's
gonna be interesting to see how it plays
out
July 1st was the first domino to fall I
would think I would think Kyrie means
the people up in Boston they think that
he's gone
so it's you know that seems to be the
worst kept secret so why not just get it
done early and I will say this little
secret about the media especially those
of us left to right over this time we
love when the guys get things done right
away the greatest news that I heard last
year was when rich Paul sent out that
statement at about 9 o'clock at night on
July 1st this is LeBron James has
decided to join the Lakers that you knew
it was gonna be a quick free agency you
know the years that these guys have had
meetings and they go on and on it's like
the worst thing when Tracy McGrady was a
free agent and he went to Orlando back
then you couldn't announce the signing
until July 30
yup July 31st I think it was so that was
a long time waiting for everything to
fall into place
from what about the Lakers they're in
there in a situation they need a little
bit of help from New Orleans possibly ad
gives back four million dollars and we
talk about one of those big dominoes
falling and you're gonna have to talk a
guy into taking less if not
significantly less amount of money so do
you go to superstar do you go for the
row player what you got well my thing is
I know that you know they're trying to
get another max slot but to me the two
legitimate max players are Kevin Durant
and Kawhi Leonard it doesn't look like
you're gonna get either one of those
guys so why not go for the role players
and try to fill out that roster and try
to do it the right way you got a pretty
good starting point with LeBron and
Anthony Davis I actually think Davis
might give back the money number one
he's in Space Jam too so maybe somehow
they could do a little you know backdoor
give them the money back that way but
that leery Frank can you do that Frank
oh no we know that doesn't happen in the
NBA
we know that buddy could do something
but the other way would be you know if
I'm him and if you figure you can make
up that money and I understand it's four
million dollars but think about how much
good publicity four million dollars
could get you if you decide to kind of
give it back and think about like you
know all the goodwill maybe he thinks
like that maybe he doesn't it's his
money he's entitled to it so I hope
Laker fans don't get too upset with
Anthony Davis who says hey listen I want
my money he's got every right to every
penny of that but I'm sure it's
something that he's considering Frank
what do you think when you hear this
DeAngelo Russell signs with the Lakers
you know what to be it'd be a pretty
interesting story and everything that
happened him and Nick Young last year
and I know you were following if you
look at the way DeAngelo Russell played
he did a really great job on the court I
think he answered a lot of questions
about his maturity both on and off the
court and I'll never forget they had a
game I believe it was in January in
Houston they were getting blown out by
the Rockets and Kenny Atkinson put
Spencer Dinwiddie in the game and he had
the answer Russell on the bench and the
Nets started making their comeback and
D'Angelo Russell was the biggest
cheerleader on the bench to me that said
a lot about him yeah where it wasn't
where wasn't I was huge
insulted that he wasn't in there I
should be in there the way his attitude
I thought that really said a lot about
him and he did a lot this past season to
really change the perception of him and
I hope he strikes it rich and free
agency as well he certainly earned it
yeah now Frank III know it's a feel-good
story I'm pulling from the kid from day
one I remember covering his draft but he
gets caught with a little substance at
the airport does that does that deter
you is he is he mature enough because
you know the LA that was too big for him
at the time just got even bigger come on
come on Frank yeah but also Ryan look at
it this way if he goes there he's going
in as the number three guy and then at
the at most because you're gonna have
LeBron Anthony Davis and there's gonna
be a ton of pressure now on Anthony
Davis because you know you're playing in
New Orleans and yes everyone
acknowledged that he was a great player
but he did only make the playoffs a
couple of times only got out of the
first round one so just like LeBron you
go play for the Lakers as a star you
know and you could say it's unfair it's
like playing for the Yankees in New York
you're being judged on championships so
getting to the playoffs not good enough
getting to an NBA Finals okay now we're
talking but ultimately they're gonna say
did you do with Jerry West Magic Johnson
Kareem will Shaq Kobe did you do what
those guys did did you come here and win
a championship and if you don't I mean I
hate to use the word failure because
LeBron James is anything but a failure
but that chapter it'll be looked at
differently if you go to LA and you
don't win so from this so in that
respect in terms of Dan's or Russell
they'll be pressure on ting but all the
pressure in the world's gonna be on
Anthony Davis and still on LeBron so
Frank how much credit does Magic Johnson
get if the Lakers win a championship
next year or is this
I mean who who do we credit here is this
is this clutch sports is this LeBron
James where do we go
I don't like the way that club sports
handled it and written ball handled it
but you can't argue with the results he
wanted to get his client to LA and
seconds like Anthony Davis wanted to be
there rich Pahl's number one client
definitely wanted Anthony Davis there
and rich ball took a hit but ultimately
he did his job he got Anthony Davis to
the Lakers I think that magic is still
going to be involved some way you know
we were joking around about tampering
kind of like meet up he can beat up with
pre agents he could talk about them in
interviews
I still think on the periphery he's
going to be involved and I think magic
also knows that he's getting a lot of
criticism for the way that he handled
his exit so I think the kind of make
good with a lot of people I think he's
gonna want to be on the side with the
Lakers and do anything that they want
and now he can do it in a role where
doesn't catch any grief and like you
said they got the trade that they wanted
I saw I think New Orleans did a great
job with getting back what they got back
but the Lakers wanted Anthony Davis and
when the dust settled they got Anthony
Davis Frank let's switch gears here to
the NBA Awards now Yanis opted to kupo
for those who didn't know he received
the MVP that is the probably the most
prestigious award outside of getting a
championship for a NBA player but guess
what Frank
he wasn't my MVP I love the kid I love
his motor I wouldn't know what he does
I'm a James Harden guy what do you stand
Frank well you're not gonna be happy
with me because I get a vote and I voted
for Jana synthetic Coco I felt you know
played both ends of the court and I get
it he plays in the Eastern Conference
but they still did win 60 games
I thought Harden really made a
compelling argument for himself over the
last few months of the year because that
it there was a time when they were in
14th place and he actually said I'm
gonna win MVP again and he carried the
team you know we've talked about LeBron
in the past elated he's carried the
Cleveland Cavaliers well last year James
Harden carried the Rockets I thought he
was great they went from 14th you know
they ended up you know getting home
court advantage in the first round but
still I I thought Yanis made a big jump
the fact that the team 160 games are
like I said both ends of the court
that's why I voted him I did both hard
and second if that makes you feel better
how about who's got a brighter future
Luca or Trey that's a tough one I looked
I love Trey young but man he is he's
small and he's got short arms that's you
know Luca dodge it's his size I'd
probably pick him but I do love the way
the Trey young is a fighter I thought he
was a fighter in college and I thought
after everyone was ready to announce
that he was a bust of a drafted I love
the way that he played the second half
of the season so I still think he's
going to be a good player but the size
unfortunately sometimes concerns me a
little bit now now Frank yesterday we
had a we had an intriguing a free agent
kind of kind of talk I don't know I
guess player to players not tampering
but uh our man six men in the year Lou
Williams and Pascal siakam the NBA's
most improved they both put some pitches
together for Kawhi Leonard do either
come in to LA or just stay in Toronto
you're Kawhi Leonard what do you do I
don't think Kawhi Leonard should lose by
the way Williams having two girlfriends
I might let me tell you something he
said he gets Player of the Year I love
him as a player I will say this I think
Hawaii the fact that he won in Toronto
if you sign for two more years I think
they can get back to at least one more
final and win so maybe he does that and
then he then he returns home but I do
think this idea of the Knicks or the
nets for Kawhi Leonard I find it hard to
believe he would leave a cold-weather
City join his third team in 11 months
and it's not going to be the Clippers I
just find that hard to believe I think
if you leave
it's the Clippers but I tend to think
you Stan what is Kawhi the best player
right now I had a top-five list I don't
know if you even want me to repeat it
out to you I but I I have Kawhi is the
best player in the NBA right now we're
where do you hold Kawhi well I think the
fact that LeBron 34 and coming off that
injury and Kevin Durant being out of the
league
I would say Hawaii's well it's
interesting though if you look at their
career numbers I think LeBron is that 27
points a game which is read
considering how many games he's played
Taranto's at 26 and Kauai is at 17
that's for his career this year I think
he was at about 26 points per game but
the guy plays both ends of the court and
it's funny to all you ever heard well
now when people say well I don't know if
he could be like Chris Middleton can he
really be good enough could you win a
championship with him as your
second-best fire didn't we constantly
hear that about Kyle Lowry all of a
sudden Kawhi Leonard shows up in Kyle
Lowry yeah he's good enough to be your
second best player and win a
championship to me that's how good Kauai
is I thought he elevated the confidence
level of everybody on the team he's a
two-way player the guy the guys a stud
and I tell you this I didn't realize he
had that kind of sense of humor during
the playoffs he was constantly up at the
podium before games I'm sorry after
games off days during practice I thought
the guy has a his a sneaky sense of
humor he's a lot smarter I think then
people gave him credit for good I think
he's really quiet so sometimes people
mistake that for him being a little
naive he's a sharp as a knife that guy
Frank you were amazing at always brother
this is Ryan Hollins still here on the
yeah Frank quick real quick rich wanted
to say thank you for the glowing praise
on PTI yesterday on his 50th birthday
calling him the king of Staten Island
wanted me to ask you who else was in the
running for king of Staten Island a
couple of people Paul Castellano okay
not shot down outside sparks steakhouse
we don't want to get into that
especially if you're Italian you don't
want to talk about that phony reality
Tony reality's also a Staten Island guy
okay and a Tony realities technically my
boss so I hope rich realizes that I gave
him King status over the guy who's
technically my boss that's how you
really should have priests raise Frank
and I thought rich I got to be honest
with you I thought he looks good for 42
years old I didn't know is 50 times
I appreciate it Frank
good stuff brother as always all right
guys keep up the good work and my best
to rich legacy but absolutely for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app